Do you see how we sniped, we got Joel on a path and now Joel has gone to a different CSP, now Joel's looking at the code of the CSP evaluator during...
By the end of this episode I'm going to have a CSP evaluator.
TechnoGeek.io slash CSP evaluator. Let's go.
Hey everyone, this is TechnoGeek here. Just wanted to give a quick shout out to our latest sponsor, Project Discovery.
Now Project Discovery makes a lot of tools that you probably know of or have even used.
One of them is Nuclei, and the latest release of Nuclei is version 3.2.
Now 3.2 comes with a lot of really awesome new features.
Two that I really wanted to highlight here for you are the authenticated scanning and the advanced fuzzing support.
Now for authenticated scanning, it used to be that you would have to do all your Nuclei scanning against unauthenticated endpoints,
or you'd have to add your cookies manually, all that kind of messy. No more.
It's all automatic. You can use existing login templates to automatically log in to your application,
and then you can run all your existing Nuclei templates against an authenticated part of the application now to really increase your coverage.
The other that I mentioned is advanced fuzzing support.
Now Nuclei had added way back in version 2.8 the ability to fuzz different things,
but now they've expanded this comprehensively across the board.
So not only can you fuzz in the normal spots, but you can fuzz within headers.
You can fuzz within cookies. You can fuzz within specific parts of the body, whether that's in JSON or XML or form data, and so many more things.
So if you want to learn more about what came in Nuclei 3.2, go ahead and check out the release blog post over at nux.gg slash podcast.
That's nux.gg slash podcast. Thanks.
Thank you.
Very excited to have you on.
We, um, I wanted, so the reason we invited you on this time right now, um, well, there's a couple of reasons really.
One, you have been pretty public with your journey into full-time bug bounty, which is cool.
Um, and I wanted to kind of interview you and sort of debrief that and see how that's been going.
And also, man, you just have the craziest bugs I've ever seen on the client side.
It's, it's really inspiring to see.
Um, and so I'm hoping we could debrief some of those things.
Um, but let's, let's go ahead and start at the very beginning, a very good place to start.
And, uh, and just give me like a, um, a little intro into your career path that landed you at full-time bug bounty.
Yeah, sure.
So hi, thanks for having me.
So, uh, my name is Johan Karlsson.
Uh, so I, I live in Sweden and, um, I'm, uh, my career path sort of, uh, began like a long time ago.
Like I'm a bit older than the average bounty hunter, I guess, uh, turning 37 now.
Uh, and so I, I was one of those kids who like doing computers, like all the time in the late nineties, early 2000, uh, playing games and doing all that stuff.
And like, I thought that I would end up like a game developer, I guess.
And I went to do high school doing programming and networking and stuff like that.
Uh, but then after, uh, high school, I decided to quit computers.
Like I decided to not touch them at all.
Uh, and I, I stuck to that for about eight years or something doing, uh, art studies instead and painting and drawing.
And was that like a, was that like a technophobia decision?
What, what, what was that?
Or you just trying to be rebellious, I guess, to my friends.
Okay.
Gotcha.
Like everyone just, uh, I mean, everyone started doing like, we, we started like a collective, I guess you call that.
Like we moved in a bunch of friends, uh, in a apartment after high school and just, uh, people did like whatever, but most of them just continued on with the technical path.
Uh, and I decided to go down this like artistic route instead.
Uh, but then, uh, so like eight years later, I, when I, uh, got my first kid or like maybe 10 years later, but, uh, yeah, I, I kind of figured out that I had to earn some money because I didn't really do it with the, with the arts.
That's the tricky part with arts.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Definitely.
How about all your, your friends who went to the computer row were kind of laughing then?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
They had already like spent, so they were like way ahead of me then.
Like already like these really good positions in, uh, tech companies and stuff.
Uh, but, uh, yes, I, I actually pretty, like, I got a job at Stockholm university at like the language department, uh, taking care of their like, uh, IT stuff.
Uh, and there I got to like play with the arts.
Uh, like doing like bash scripting and stuff, uh, just to take care of this, like two rooms of computers.
And then I kind of got the, the feeling again, uh, that this is pretty fun and I'm also like pretty good at it.
And, uh, then maybe like I should do it because it's like way easier to, to get the money that way.
So then I actually took, uh, a bachelor degree in computer science.
Uh, so that was like, uh, I started 2018, uh, so 2021, uh, during COVID, uh, I was done with that.
And I got my first job as, um, so I was educated as just like a, uh, like an engineer to be able to do like whatever.
But I ended up in this as often happened, you get like a job and they say like, can you, do you know, react?
And I was like, yeah, sure.
Sure.
Of course.
Give me a week.
Yeah.
They are, they are like interconnected.
It was interesting to see, cause you, you listed a, in this doc when we were kind of getting
like the, all the info we need to know about you, you listed a bachelor's thesis, which mentioned
to GitLab, which I thought was hilarious.
Cause I was like, man, this guy's like writing a thesis on GitLab.
It's no wonder that he always hacks on it.
Right?
Exactly.
And I also like, I kind of got stuck on GitLab.
So it's, I've been doing like, I didn't even know that bug bounty existed before I started
that like thesis project.
And since then I just been like, keep keeping at them.
I guess.
Dude.
It's, it's great when you've originally, you know, uncovered bug bounty and your eyes just
kind of open up to that world.
It's like, ah, I just, I, I so clearly remember as well.
My, my first experience with, with bug bounty, uh, just being at this, this class, uh, that
I was teaching actually.
And Tommy DeVos just kind of bust into this classroom at my school.
And it's just like, Hey, bug bounty.
And I'm like, who are you?
You know?
And I'm like, and, and, and, who are you?
But also that's very interesting.
Um, so I had a similar experience because I was doing this like ethical hacking course
that I could, uh, apply for, uh, when doing, uh, so that was the last year of my, um, uh,
bachelor, uh, in computer science.
You could like pick some courses and I picked, uh, an ethical hacking course.
And during that course, which was more like a CTF thing, like you had to capture flags
in a virtual environment, uh, uh, that kind of hacking, like scanning and mapping things
and, uh, finding flags.
Uh, but the, you could get like additional points in the course if you found bugs, uh,
in bug bounties.
So that was my friend.
I went to hacker once.
I actually, I could see like when I signed up, I just signed up and I got so like, um,
kind of like scared for the whole concept.
Like how could I ever like find something here?
Like this seems so foreign to me.
So, uh, yeah.
That's really interesting.
So did your professor, your professor must've known what bug bounty was or whoever's running
the course.
Yeah.
Uh, and he, he was actually, so he was then later my thesis, uh, guidance or whatever.
What do you call it?
I have no idea.
Joel.
Your, your, your thesis, your advisor or whatever.
Yeah.
That's right.
I would say he actually, he was part of like picking a target and, and stuff like that.
So, uh, he knew what it was definitely.
Yeah.
And, um, so you said you get extra points for this.
So what you're saying, Johan is you tanked an exam and then you're like, how do I pass
this class?
And he goes like, all right, gotta find a bug.
I'm back myself into a corner now.
Backs against the wall.
Help me.
Um, so, uh, no, that, that's awesome, man.
That that's a cool path.
And, and I love always hearing the ways so many people, you know, end up into bug bounty
and get to where we're at.
Um, so I want to come back around to some of your experiences now that you're a full-time
hunter, but first let's jump into some of these bugs, man, because I was reading through this,
you know, some of the bugs that you wanted to talk about on this pod and whoo, they are
awesome.
Um, really like very cool.
Um, and this first one is a, is a CSP bypass.
Um, I guess taking an HTML injection and, and exploiting it in a really, um, CSP dense
environment.
So you want to talk a little bit about that one?
Yeah.
Uh, so, and this is really like my, this is where I really like thrive when I get to do
this.
I can tell.
And like, first of all, like I, uh, it's my, the perfect situation for me as well, because
I didn't really, I didn't find the bug, uh, myself, like the injection points.
I was, uh, contacted by Sudi, I guess like Sudi.
Yeah.
I will not try to pronounce, uh, people's names here, but, and, uh, welcome to my world.
So this guy, like Ross eight, seven, six.
Yeah.
He, he found like an injection in, um, where you could just like, uh, in an input field
in GitHub, you could enter something and you got like an error message back and that rendered,
like whatever you put there, just rendered straight back.
So it was like completely unfiltered, uh, injection.
And I guess they could have just like, and they did just report that and they would probably
have, uh, fixed it and, uh, done everything, but you always want to like gain, gain that
like last step.
So.
Especially you, I'm reading these reports and I'm seeing like, oh, okay.
He got to the last step.
Oh no, that's not the last step.
There's another, oh, he's going.
He keeps on going.
One more.
Yeah.
I was really, I was happy because I know that they contacted some more people and I was
the only one who actually figured out how to like bypass this.
Uh, feels good, man.
So on, uh, on GitHub, they have this CSP that the, the script source is just one domain.
So there's nothing else.
There's no nonces or like anything.
So either we have to find something on, um, that domain or you're kind of screwed.
Uh, and they actually are one of the ones that actually also had like this, uh, form action
thing that I always nag about, like trying to figure out because people miss it all the
time.
Talk to me about that because I had, you know, Joel and I were kind of prepping for this
pot that we were talking about.
It's like, man, I really have rarely ever seen this.
Um, so this is like a, a CSP directive that allows you to control where a form is being
submitted into inside of that environment.
Right?
Exactly.
And, uh, so the, the strange thing is that that's not the fetch based request.
Uh, and that means that it's not covered by default source.
Uh, so it's one of the exceptions to default source.
So even if you put default source in there, it will not cover, um, form action.
Wow.
So, so default source is only for, is that only for fetch based stuff?
Yeah.
It's like, it's only for fetch based stuff, but fetch based is like a really wide term.
So it's, it covers more than you.
It's not just like someone using the fetch, uh, framework.
There's a lot of stuff.
Is that a descriptive term or is that a, a technical term in like,
it's a technical term in the, the specification of a JavaScript or.
Wow.
Yeah.
And, and, and how does that differentiate from connect source?
Uh, and, and, and like is connect source, is that going to be different from, is that
also going to be fetch based or is that.
I think it will actually get blocked as well.
Uh, I think it's only like four, like really strange things that are, uh, not covered by this
default source.
Okay.
And form action is like the only, like the only thing that you can actually exploit in my
experience.
Um, but it's, so people often miss that.
And it's also like on, if you go to this regular, like CSP evaluator that everyone is using from Google,
that one will not tell you about, um, the lack of form action.
Uh, and I, I had a discussion on Twitter with, uh, this guy from Google about that.
And they had their reasons, like that validator is only for like cross site scripting, uh,
ish things.
Like it's not supposed to tell you everything about CSP because people are using this in
like all these different ways.
Uh, but I, I still think that it should have like a mention of, uh, yeah, it is called the
CSP evaluator, not the XSS CSP evaluator.
Yeah.
But if you read in the, like the description, it says something about like, try to have like
a safe, uh, CSP for like injections or whatever.
I feel like I can already hear Bebex in the background, like writing a critical thinking
version of this that looks at everything.
Dude, dude, this is a little bit of a tangent, but Bebex is like really like on top of devving
in this community, man, like he's building the CVSS advisor, the SSRF sheriff, a bunch
of Kyto stuff.
It's like, anyway, shout out to our boy Bebex.
And I know that there, there is like one other CSP evaluator that I have been using and that
might actually catch this.
Um, I haven't really, but I usually just go for this one as well because it's easier.
And then I just look for it if it's missing.
It's important too, because you know, that's kind of the go-to route, right?
If you, if you can't get scripts execution, you know, you're going to get a lot of
information, you know, you're going to be submitting forms and trying for, for, uh, C-SURFS, or
you're going to be doing like autofill password exfiltration.
Um, so it's, it's, I think, I think it's a really nice directive to have in place.
Yeah.
So there's this one called CSP validator.org.
This might be the other one you're thinking of, and it looks like it does have some stuff
mentioned about, um, the, uh, the, the form action, um, clause.
Interesting.
Yeah.
So I think potentially, I don't know, I haven't tested it to see like what it does, but, um,
potentially this might also be, I'm not sure if this is just for validation or if this looks
for sort of the issues that you, um, that you, that you get surfaced with the Google CSP validator,
but that could also be an option.
I'm not sure, but definitely worth, uh, if you find, if you find a link to that, let us know.
We'll put it in the description.
Yeah.
I will try to find it.
Uh, but it's definitely like one, it's my go-to thing as well.
Like if I cannot do anything else, I try to do a form and like try to argue that you can
do like out of fill, uh, bugs, uh, some program programs, uh, except that some doesn't really
care, but, uh, it's still like a valid exploitation path.
I think that you can create like a form field, even like hidden or whatever, uh, in a page
and it will get out of filled and maybe even auto submitted and whatever.
And you steal credentials and stuff.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
I think it's valid in my opinion.
Um, I also didn't know this, but the CSP evaluator itself is actually open source on GitHub.
So if you want to extend it, if you want to extend it and, uh, just add that functionality,
but they don't want it.
They don't want it.
Do you see how, how we, we sniped, we got Joel on a path and now Joel has gone to a different
CSP.
Now Joel's looking at the code of the CSP evaluator.
By the end of this episode, I'm going to have a CSP evaluator written.
Yeah.
Technogeek.io slash CSP evaluator.
Let's go.
Um, okay.
I'm sorry, Johan back to, so we've grilled you on CSP enough now.
Yeah, go ahead.
Now.
So one of the things that I wanted to do because I could inject like arbitrary HTML, right?
So there was like a form in the page.
So the other thing that I usually think about then is to like, just to form hijacking.
Uh, so you could do like, uh, add these like input elements and you own the input element.
You say like form action and form.
So you can like change the actions and targets and stuff off the form.
And you could potentially then, if you can do that, you usually can steal like CSRF tokens because you can change the target of the word action of the form and you can submit it and you get the CSRF and maybe you can like escalate from that.
Um, so the first.
It's interesting.
So it's on the input element itself, right?
Yeah.
Like the, the, the, so it can be outside of the form because you can also put like a form.
You can point it to which form your.
Okay.
So does it take over the entire form or does it just take over those specific elements?
Like it takes over whatever you, so you can, you, it will add itself to the form.
So everything that's already in the form will still be there, but you can change the action and you can change the target and you can change some other stuff.
Cool.
Yeah.
Very cool technique.
So the problem then was that I couldn't, um, like exfiltrated anyhow, because it was quite strict, like form action.
I think that you could actually hit some, uh, other end points with it.
Uh, I don't remember, but, uh, uh, what I ended up trying to do was to actually change the form action to like an internal, to just hijack the form to like target some, uh, internal API.
Uh, so just doing like a client side.
Uh, attack instead.
So like changing it.
Then you can also add like all of these new, like input fields that will also be, so you could fill it with data that this API route would need.
Then.
Uh, so I was really happy with that and I fired it off and nothing happened.
And I was like super confused.
And then I, uh, so this was the only time.
And the first time I've encountered this, that they had like CSRF protection per form.
It's like each, a form.
It's crazy.
They fetch the form and it has a CSRF token, but it's only valid for that path that it's, uh, uh, created for.
Do you, did you experiment to see if, did you experiment to see if it was like deeper than that?
So like, for example, on a page that has two forms, you couldn't swap one CSRF from one form to another.
No, it's actually.
Or is it.
Uh, I think it actually gets back to like the final bypass later that it's actually used this like hot wire stuff.
Because it fetches the forms as like a building block and puts it in the, uh, the page and some where in the back end of this rails thing, you can enable this like CSRF by.
By.
Perform thing.
And it creates this protection or for your whole page sort of.
Wow.
So that's some sort of feature in rails.
I haven't looked too deep into it.
I used to Google it and figure out like, okay, so this will not work.
That's super frustrating.
Yeah.
Uh, but so, so that will lead into the actual bypass.
Which is like when I was like researching this, I saw that everything was nested in this like weird, uh, elements that I haven't never seen before.
Like turbo frames.
Um, so like I, and I searched in the page for it and there was like a lot of turbo frame mentions everywhere.
Uh, so I, I started Googling for that and, uh, found that this is a part of a, uh, uh, kind of new addition, like a new framework to rails, which is called hot wire.
I don't know if it's usable outside of rails as well, but it's sort of like Ruby on rails version of what you talked about last week.
Then, uh, uh, the HTMX thing.
Oh, it's like, uh, HTML over the wire.
Uh, which is, uh, if you look into it, it's actually a concept that exists in all like the big frameworks.
So Laravel has its own, that is called like live wire or something.
And, uh, Phoenix live view, which is, uh, based on, uh, uh, yeah, whatever you call that, uh, elixir.
Uh, and some, like, there are a lot of these and most like, so these ones are actually tied to a specific like framework and that makes them a bit harder to exploit.
Like HTMX is just a JavaScript library and these are like framework libraries that also have like a small JavaScript, uh, piece that, uh, you can hook into.
So back-end component and a front-end component.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Uh, yeah.
And, uh, so I can also add that they, the other two guys already had this like drag and drop, uh, POC, uh, at this time.
So the way to exploit this was actually, you, you kind of like, you are on the attacker page and you drag some image to somewhere and you drop it and it kind of closes itself and it drops in.
So it's a bit like you have to do a lot of like, uh, user interaction, but I still think that this is, uh, like you encounter this everywhere, especially if you have used like proton has their own, like, uh, um, what do you call this?
Like a capture thing, uh, that works exactly like that.
You have to drag like a small puzzle piece.
That's true.
That's a great point.
So, so users are really like, uh, they're used nowadays to do these kinds of actions.
Without even thinking about it.
I think it's a valid, yeah, yeah.
Uh, but yeah, so back to the, the hot wire stuff.
And so I was actually, let me, I'm sorry, let me interrupt and get one clarifying factor there.
So when you said an image, the way you're doing that is you're taking the text that you want to insert.
You're putting that in the alt tag of the image and then you're dragging it on there.
Is that what populates it or is it something else?
No, it's just a JavaScript.
Uh, so the, the, the, the person thinks that they are dragging an image, but when you click it, there's like an JavaScript event that listens for that.
And it fills your clipboard.
Uh, or like, yeah, it, it, it, your drag keeps.
Okay.
Yeah.
Your drag thing.
It fills it with this payload.
Interesting.
Okay.
And when you release it, it will fill this, uh, uh, form field.
Very nice.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
Um, and, uh, so yeah, so I, I found this hot wire stuff that I hadn't seen before and it was, it seemed pretty simple.
Like there, there's like three parts to it, which one of them is not really, uh, interesting for this, uh, which is like this event based thing that is, it cannot cause XSS in on itself because the events are only like made in a connection to the backend.
So it's, uh, it's not the same as HMX there, but the other random question really quick.
Yeah.
When you're, when you're discovering this and you're going down this rabbit hole, is this through source code analysis or is this from more of a black box perspective?
Uh, I just, I found these tags, uh, in GitHub, like in the page source, uh, or like the DOM, uh, and they confused me because they were like, they're not regular elements.
So they must mean something.
So that was my thinking.
So when I started Googling it, I just found this, uh, the documentation essentially, uh, where they discovered.
Gotcha.
Where they described that there existed like two concepts, like, uh, uh, uh, what was the name of them again?
What?
The turbo.
Yeah.
The turbo frame and the turbo stream.
Mm.
So the turbo frame is quite similar to the HTMX thing that they are, you have a turbo frame with an ID in your DOM, in your page.
It's interesting.
Yeah.
So with these, like, how do we identify these?
Are you, are you literally just like crepping through the source code looking for any sort
of like, um, dot whatever, like clearly a class CSS selector, like an ID CSS selector
that's put into place and, and then trying to figure out if they're binding any functions
To these sort of classes existing, or is it just reading through the whole thing?
And like, well, how are you identifying these?
Is there some trick to this or?
No, I've been doing it like, uh, all the different ways, like, uh, putting a break point
at the beginning of the, the JavaScript just to see if it adds something.
Uh, but then also just like looking at all the places where it's actually using like CSS
selectors to get elements, uh, and to see if, and for, for, yeah, usually they have some
sort of like main functionality that's kind of like kickstarts, uh, whatever all the other
JS on the page is gonna do.
And you can kind of see there if they're like trying to, uh, initialize, uh, initialize.
This reminds me of a bug that I found that is, of course, hacker one, my two weeks is up
right now in the middle of this pod.
So now I've got to like,
It's always on Mondays.
I don't know.
Somehow it's always in the middle of the pod when I'm trying to like get into my bugs to
like talk about something.
But the only thing I've ever found that is remotely similar to this is essentially what
you just mentioned, which was, um, hijacking selectors, um, for, for your, your purposes.
So I remember in this one scenario, I believe it was a WAF based scenario, um, where I could
only get through like on click or something like that.
And it was, and it was on an element that you couldn't click on or something.
And I was able to like name it as specific ID and add a specific ID to the element.
And then later down it would say like, click this ID, like this idea or whatever dot click.
And they would hijack it and pop the XSS.
And I was like, I am a legend, you know, like, and then, you know, Johan rolls up in here with
like this 16 step chain.
Um, no.
No.
So just, just to, just to summarize this for the listeners as well.
Hmm.
Um, like I mentioned before, this is a really great example of how a hacker adapts in a, in
a different environment, right?
Um, most of us, like I mentioned before are not really exposed to hyper CSP environments.
And as we continue to, um, move that direction in the industry where CSP becomes more widely accepted and more, um, you know, just as time passes and it gets a part of everything as default, um, we're going to have to adapt in this way.
And so it's really helpful for us to look at examples like Johan and how he's adapted already over time to, um, bypass these, because we're going to be doing a lot of gadget searching like this in the future.
So I'm going to go ahead and start studying up on, on all this and try to be ready for that shift in the industry.
And I think it's really, um, a great thing for the community that a lot of your reports, uh, are, are, are disclosed in, in, on GitLab.
And then, you know, you're doing interviews like this, where we can kind of talk through the mentality, uh, because otherwise trying to get good examples on how to find these gadgets and that sort of thing would be, would be really tricky.
Um, not going to lie though.
Um, not going to lie though, I'm a little sad.
There's not like some, yeah, just go to the console and like run this and like list every single, you know, listener for this specific thing.
Um, I mean, I think if, if I were, I, so this is probably one of my problems as that I have with my, like, when I do my hunting is that I'm very unstructured.
And I'm like, I, there's probably like some really good ways if you could like sit down and just figure out what to grep for or whatever.
But I'm, I really don't do that.
You know, I'm just like reading it again and again, and just coming back to the source code and just, um, yeah.
Hey man, that, that approach always, you know, that approach works well in the beginning when we're, you know, sort of developing this mentality and it gets you through the first, you know, however many.
Um, I'll shout, shout out Matan Bear here.
Uh, cause I know he, he also does a bunch of really interesting client side stuff and he's shown me some, um, things that you can put into the dev console that will list a bunch of really useful, um, listeners and that sort of thing.
So I don't have permission to disclose it yet.
So I, but I know he's listening to this episode.
So, uh, you know, Matan Bear, go ahead and like, yeah, figure out a way to do this, uh, list all of these like CSS selectors or whatever, um, in the source code.
And then we can, you know, sort of find some more gadgets like this.
Cause it's really, really interesting stuff here.
Um, all right.
So that was shit.
Johan.
That was the first bug.
We haven't done anything yet.
Um, tell you what, let's move.
Let's move, let's move a little bit.
I see why your reports are so long.
You know, that was one of the things we were going to talk about, you know, um, later on in your full-time bug bounty struggles or whatever.
Um, but I'm starting to see why this is happening.
Um, tell you what, let's, let's go into this, uh, pipeline bug.
Yeah.
And let's keep this one a little bit more brief so that we can, uh, get access to some of the other goodies that are lay on the other side of the technical content this time around.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I, I mean, so this is more the, the, the pipeline, this is actually my, it's my only critical finding on the GitLab.
Uh, so I'm also really proud of it.
Like it was one of my, one of my things on my to-do list, uh, to finally find like one critical after spending, uh, I guess I had spent two years when I found it or something like that.
Um, and it's, it's kind of represents the other part of my, uh, my hunting, which is not based on like, uh, technical things in the browser or like knowledge about HTML or whatever.
It's like, uh, just, uh, business logic application bug.
Um, so.
So, and it's also, it showcases like how I kind of work in GitLab.
So I saw this report.
Uh, I have seen a lot of reports like reading through when people have been able to like trigger pipelines on in GitLab as other users.
Um, and I have read them and they have also always been like a medium impact and I have been like researching, like there must be something you can do with this that it's like higher impact than this medium.
Like they all seems a little off.
Yeah.
I mean, but so what you usually can do, like what people have shown as a POC is that you can like download, download source code from other repositories with this.
Like if you trigger it as a victim, you can download there, like maybe a private repo or something.
And that's, it has a high impact, but they are staying really strict to their like CSP.
Uh, um, no CVS says CVS delegation.
Yeah.
Uh, so, and if you don't find a way to like escalate it from only reading stuff, it will not get just confidentiality.
Okay.
Um, but so, so I had this dream of like one day.
Uh, be able to run the pipeline as an arbitrary user, because I thought that I could do something better with it.
Yeah.
Uh, and, uh, I was lucky to see one of these, uh, fixes going out for, uh, this guy.
Now I, I, I forgot to look up, uh, the name of him, but this other person found a bug where you could do this.
And I found a bypass to it.
Uh, and so this is again, like sort of like where I.
Feel most comfortable and like where I shine is when I get some sort of like foothold and I start to escalate it and like show impact.
Then when I, uh, when I feel like it's getting really fun.
We talk about this from the perspective of an exploitationist essentially, like, like I think your, your expertise here is an act as an exploitation as somebody who can take a little.
Well, just a little, just a little something that's a little bit off, you know, and turn it into some big, huge thing.
Um, and, and versus somebody who.
I don't have a specific name for it yet, but somebody who finds that initial.
A foothold.
It's, it's a little bit more recon centric.
A lot of time that's actually not, not even necessarily in the traditional sense of recon, like, all right, we're scanning assets running, you know, port scans or whatever.
But, um, somebody who spends time.
Uh, fingerprinting the whole application and understanding how all these different pieces come together and finds that one little piece.
That's a little bit off.
And then, you know, you can either hand it off to somebody who's a, a talented exploitationist or try to attempt that exploitation yourself.
But I think, um, just in an attempt to framework eyes that whole, uh, you know, the different roles of, of, um, hacking, I think those two roles are, are pretty clear and.
They're, they're pretty different from each other too.
Uh, just because you're, you're, you can find a lot of, you know, footholds doesn't mean you can always take it the full distance.
So, um, it's cool to see, uh, a very talented exploitationist here.
Yeah.
So, so what I had seen in the documentation, so this also like just in the documentation, I had seen that if you trigger pipeline, it will run as the user who triggered the pipeline.
So that's all fine.
It will run in the, so I could only do it.
So I run the pipeline as another user, but in my project, can you, can you give a, um, explanation to what a pipeline is in this context?
Oh yeah.
So a CI CD like pipeline, which is whenever you push something to a code base or whatever in GitHub or GitHub.
Uh, it will more often than not trigger a pipeline, which it will build and run some tests and whatnot.
Sure.
Okay.
In a separate environment, like, uh, in one of these runners, which are like a sandboxed environment somewhere, but it will also have access to a lot of like environment variables and stuff like that.
Uh, which is interesting to get access to.
Uh, but so the, the initial bug here is that you can run like another user, but it's only in your project.
So you already have access to everything in the project.
So it's not that impactful, but then you can also read some of the victims like projects.
But this thing that people hadn't really utilized before is the, it was like in the end of the documentation for this functionality.
It said that you could also trigger like down words pipelines or whatever, like creating a chain of pipelines through different projects.
Uh, interesting.
Uh, from your, from this pipeline, you can trigger another pipeline in another project.
Um, and this is actually kind of locked down now.
So they have fixed like the main issue with that.
Uh, but at this time.
Would you have control over those contexts or would it just like, would it just trigger it?
It will just trigger it, uh, in pro like you could sort of target the, the branch, I guess.
Like you, you want to do it in the main branch, uh, if the user have access there.
Uh, but what you could, so this is also like not super impactful at that time.
So that's maybe why they haven't, hadn't really cared about it before.
But I also like went deeper in the documentation.
It also said like, yeah, you can also specify some variables to overwrite.
Like when you do this new trigger, you could add variables and you can also overwrite variables that are already present in this other project.
Uh, so then I started to look for a gadget where this could lead to, because if you just trigger the pipeline, you have no control of like what's happening.
You cannot leak anything more or whatever.
Um, but if you can overwrite some variables that potentially that variable is used in like a curl command or whatever, and you can like, um, start leaking stuff.
So that was my, like the first impact I had there was that I could add.
I found, uh, one template.
So when you build the CI pipeline in these places, you often use like a bunch of different small CI stuff.
And some of them are from templates that like GitLab provides that are like helping you with like code quality.
So that was the, the, the final one that I found that a lot of people use.
We're going to increase the code quality a lot here.
In a second, I can feel it.
So that one especially was like, uh, they were doing, so let's see.
Uh, okay.
No.
So this one was actually doing like secret detection.
So that's good.
Okay.
It was actually trying to detect secrets.
Nice.
But, uh, but this one was actually, you could specify, they are specifying the image.
So like the, the Docker image that the, the, the pipeline is going to use that is specified through
to detect the, okay.
Okay.
I see.
Just, just to say like, so whenever you trigger pipeline, it will find the Docker image to use
like as the base for that, uh, that pipeline run.
Uh, and so here I could inject whatever I could target it to like, like, the, the pipeline run.
And so that makes it possible to me to do like, I could run whatever code I want now.
So I have like RCE essentially, but in, uh, in this kind of like pipeline.
Okay.
Uh, but still that makes it possible to, for me to do a lot more than just like trigger the pipeline.
I can now control the output of this, uh, this pipeline, and I can also read all the variables and everything.
And, uh, and then just to the, so the final step for me to prove that I can do that.
And then the last step for me to prove to GitLab that this was a critical was to just read through their own discussions.
And I found this mention of, so GitLab in their pipeline, they have a variable that contains a real access token, uh, that they use to do like more like sensitive stuff.
Uh, and I just saw that they mentioned it in a bunch of places.
I, uh, my report essentially was like, I made this mocked up version of this and I sent it.
And then I said, like, I pretty, I'm pretty certain that I can do this to your environment right now.
And I can get this token.
Did you didn't even do it in prod?
No, no, no, no.
Oh man.
This is where like, that's the best place to test stuff.
You know, I don't know.
I don't know.
Yeah, no, that, that makes, that makes sense though.
Yeah.
Do you want to try to respect that?
But I did actually like, usually I, I let things like take its time, but this time I actually reached out to some of the security people on Twitter.
So this was of course on a Friday.
Oh no.
Uh, so I just reached out to them and said like, I think that this is bad.
Um, and then they jumped on it directly.
And on Monday they had the patch, uh, out.
Well, it makes sense.
You know, you you've got a team like GitLab, you know, with a highly reputable team.
Uh, and so to, to be able to not necessarily take that all the way and do it in prod and hand them their access token.
Uh, you know, it, it, you still have a decent amount of trust that they're gonna not do you wrong.
I did actually, I did like, I forked GitLab, of course.
So I had like a real, a similar environment so I can prove that it worked.
That's good.
So it was, yeah.
So it was, uh, my POC was like really similar to.
Yeah.
And for sure.
I think like, I, it'd be very rare to have a program where you have something like this, where you say I've decided to stop.
And I'm, I'm telling it to you now, I'm pretty sure this does this, but I want you to check it versus going ahead and doing it.
And then having them to like deal with that aftermath.
I've heard of plenty of examples of hackers where that has not gone.
Yeah.
And I have no idea what happens if I trigger a pipeline, maybe because it could also trigger like a deploy or whatever.
And like, oh, okay.
That makes a lot more sense now.
Oh, you're talking about the Git.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
So, so, so in my report, I targeted like the Git lab's main.
So, uh, yeah.
Okay.
So I had no idea of like what would happen if I did it.
So I just wanted to, to prove, prove to them that I have, I have all the pieces to actually run this now, uh, in the Git lab main repo.
So wait a second, potentially if you had leaked to this token and have access to these repos now, right?
Right access.
You could have backdoored the, the Git lab code base.
Is that accurate?
Yeah.
Oh, that's the, that is, that is nasty, dude.
That would have been so bad.
I see why you didn't do it.
No, no, but it was, uh, it's again, it's like, it proves that you, if you spend the time escalating something, you can make it like, you can actually prove that it is as bad as you, you as like a, a hunter believes.
Wow.
A lot of times when you stop earlier, uh, they might not agree with you.
Like, but if you build this scenario that is very like plausible, I think it's easier to get it through triage.
Very good.
Okay.
So let me, let me just sort of summarize this one really quick to get, to get, get through it.
So first of all, you're, you're triggering this pipeline as any user because of a, I guess this is a pipeline on your own repo because of the fallback thing.
Is that right?
Yeah.
So that, uh, exactly.
So there, there was this functionality that I sort of like built upon from this earlier report where you sort of ran some sort of, uh, uh, uh, just like maintenance, uh, uh, thingy.
It's some functionality that was broken.
And, and, and so you're able to build upon that functionality.
You're able to spoof the, the, the latest committer.
So now you can say, okay, somebody committed to this repo and now I'm gonna delete the bot or whatever, and have it fall back to that, to that user run the pipeline and then expel that, that token, which is associated with an arbitrary user.
So, uh, then you're using that token to trigger a different pipeline, but via this like downstream pipeline feature that you found about in the documentation.
And that will trigger a pipeline with a specific set of variables that you provide from your malicious pipeline.
And then that will, and then using that, you find a gadget that allows you to specify an arbitrary Docker, um, file or a Docker repo or a Docker image.
There you go.
That's the one I was like, I know there's a word for this, uh, a Docker image and that, that Docker image gets pulls into the runner executed.
So now you've got X code execution inside the, the CI pipeline on this specific repo.
And then you can exfiltrate access tokens.
Yes.
So I, I sort of like skipped over the, the initial part there that you mentioned, but yeah, it's, uh, wow.
It was, uh, uh, it was fun, but actually like, I think it's the only time when I actually like properly celebrated.
Like I went out and like bought some flowers for my wife.
There you go, dude.
That's see, that's great.
And that's actually.
Perfect transition there, Johan, because we can move into the full-time bug bounty conversation with that as well.
And one of the things that Mariah and I do and something that I've been kind of public about on the pod, because I think it's a really good, um, really good.
Uh, practice in bug bounty is doing a proper celebration when you crush something.
Um, and, and so, yeah, it's good.
It's good to see that you've actually, you actually pulled that off.
And it's sweet to say that you went and bought some flowers as your celebration versus like mine of like buying a hot tub or something like that.
So, so, so do you, do you have other.
Yeah, go ahead.
Go ahead.
No, most of the time I'm pretty bad at like celebrating.
It's more like I get this feeling of, uh, like if I, I get frustrated when I fail and when I succeed, I'm just like, okay, like did it move on.
And, uh, so usually I don't get that, uh, in that celebration mode.
Unfortunately, I, I should do that more often as well.
Yeah, absolutely.
I would definitely recommend that.
And that when, when you said you're often failing, it actually reminded me of something I wanted to ask you about the CSP bugs.
Um, these gadgets that we talked about, right?
The script gadgets, um, would you say that the, they are often there?
Like, is this something that often exists?
Like when you're presented with a, with a foothold and you need to bypass the CSPs in, in the complexity of this modern era's JavaScript frameworks and everything that gets bundled into a page.
Would you say these gadgets that affect specific, you know, classes or specific data attributes, would you say that they're often in place that allow you to do what you need to do?
I think that they are probably way more common in like big complex applications.
Okay.
Uh, so, but I, I would say like they're probably, they probably exist in all of these, the, the big things that you look at.
Uh, wow, dude, I wonder, I wonder how many good HTML injections I've found.
I mean, coming from like a dev background, like myself, I know that.
So when you're working with these like frameworks, like even with react or in Git labs case, they use the view.
Uh, and sometimes you just have this, like one piece of functionality that doesn't really like, it's too hard to like shoehorn down in this like framework and just make some quick, uh, like custom JavaScript on the side that deals with some.
Some error or something like pop up or like, you're going to have like, uh, so one, one of the ones I found on Git lab was like this.
Uh, they just wanted to show some, like we're doing this new feature pop up thing.
And you have to get that out like really quickly and like building it correctly might take a lot of time.
Some junior dev pushed this through or something like that.
Yeah.
Script it, script it together.
Uh, so definitely like have a look in these like special JS, like the utility folders.
Interesting.
Where they, they store their like custom code because that's, what's breaking.
Like it's way harder to get into like in react or whatever you, you, there, you know, where you to look, uh, look for it.
It's like they dangerously set in, in your HTML or whatever it's called.
Um, very cool, very cool stuff.
Hey guys, real quick.
I just wanted to give a shout to the hacker content team.
They have been absolutely killing it the past couple months, taking the content from the podcast and condensing it down into consumable social media posts, whether it be shorts or text posts or whatever.
They've been rocking it.
So, uh, I just wanted to give them a shout out and let you know that they do all sorts of cybersecurity content as well as social media management.
They do technical blogs, they do, uh, comprehensive social media management.
Uh, so if your organization could benefit from any of those types of services, make sure you head over to hackercontent.com, drop them a line and mention the podcast when you do to get your first month of cybersecurity content marketing services for free.
All right.
Let's get back to the pod.
So I got us a little bit off track there, jumping back into the, uh, the, the scripting stuff, but, um, let's move now, I guess a little bit more into.
The full-time bug bounty stuff.
So you've been doing it now for like what?
Two months, two months.
Yeah.
Two months.
All right.
How you feeling, man?
Do you love it?
Is it amazing?
Is it everything you ever wanted it to be?
It's, uh, it's really strange.
Uh, it's great in some ways.
So like background, uh, it's like I decided to take, to ask my job essentially for three months, uh, uh, like pay unpaid leave.
Yeah.
Just to try this out.
Uh, uh, and, uh, they were like, they were kind enough, I can say, but it's also like, uh, in Sweden, you actually are allowed to, uh, do like up to six months of unpaid leave to try to start a company.
Really?
Okay.
That's cool.
Um, I, I don't think they could say no, but, but anyhow, so I, um, yeah.
So the main goal has been to see if like spending full time on this, like, would it give me like a lot of like, would it enhance like my experience?
Money.
Would it give me a lot of money?
Would it enhance my money?
It's just a plausible way to survive.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
Would it give you a lot of, or would it enhance what?
No, but no, both.
Uh, like, would I find it because I find it really interesting and I spend a lot of time on it, but usually like in my regular work environment, like I do my full time work and then I come home and I take care of my family.
And then like, I spend two hours at night doing this and I don't do like anything else.
Right.
So this is also like, can I get back some free time and can I still be successful?
Or can I feel like not stressed about it?
And like all of those.
So those are the questions that that's that you actually just read off the list of questions that I had for you there.
And I will say like, um, you know, you've mentioned your family and, and I've got some, some, uh, family expansions that have happened recently.
And one of the things that I've been really grateful for inside of that environment, um, you know, when family is taking up more time and more, you know, investment and that sort of thing, which is great.
And I love, um, that during the day I do have control of that, you know, I have control of my, my things that I'm looking at.
You know, I can look at things that I think are interesting.
Whereas before when I was single is like, okay, you know, I could do my day job and then I'd have like a couple hours, you know, or more than a couple hours, you know, a decent amount of time afterwards where I could dive into these things that I'm more interested in.
And I think as your family grows and as your responsibilities to your family get bigger and bigger, that, that time sort of shrinks and it becomes more awesome to be able to do bug bounty full time because you can dive deep into something you're interested during your work hours.
Yeah. Yeah. And I mean, I've been listening to like all the pods and stuff that exists with these people who are doing it full time and like giving tips and tricks.
And so just to, to preface this as well, like I, I made sure to, so I have my company now where I get my bounties too.
And I had like more than enough to pay for like my salary and everything for these three months, like from starting out.
So I, I would survive like without doing this. So, and that's one of the things that you have to kind of consider when you have a family.
So as well, like you have to, I have to pay like my mortgage and like all of that stuff.
So, so you set that up, you've got that in place, you're, and then you're feeling pretty confident going into this, this three months of like, right, either way, I'm going to be able to pay myself.
So, you know, the bills are going to be paid and then worse comes to worse.
I can just go back to this company after three months and, and resume my normal life.
So what, what I, what I could lose is my self-confidence.
If I would not find anything for three months, like doing this full time, that would be hard.
So I was a bit nervous in the beginning because I had like, I hadn't done like anything for January.
And I started doing some stuff in February, leading up to March, then when I was going to start.
So I was a bit nervous that I had like, my pipeline was empty and, uh, uh, yeah.
Yeah.
Uh, but so far it's been, I'm surprised that I'm still like in lack of time.
I get, I got so much more time now, but I don't know what I spend it on.
It's just like, uh, still like the day just passes so quickly.
And, uh, I still only have like my work hours.
Like I, I leave my kids at school and preschool at eight in the morning.
And then I get back and I start working and I'm like four or five, they come back.
So then it's like, um, then it's over.
Yeah.
Uh, and then maybe I do some things, uh, later in the evening as well.
Nice.
But I've been trying to, uh, also like do more of like the home, like, uh, the shores and stuff.
Right.
So I haven't been working eight hours a day, maybe like six hours or something like that.
Yeah.
And, and so, you know, in that six hours you're, you're focusing on primarily like GitLab or,
are, have you switched around targets much?
Are you deep diving one target or.
Yeah.
I had, I have my, like the three, a couple of goals that I've wrote up, like on this blog post that I never posted.
Uh, okay.
That's the kind of stuff we'd love to get into here on the pod.
Tell me about this blog post you never posted.
Yes.
I, I listed some stuff like the number one, like get organized, uh, notes, automation, templates, scripts, like all of that stuff.
Uh, and then like deep dive one or two targets, like new targets, uh, write three.
Uh, blog posts and apply for a talk, like a, or wasp talk or like whatever.
Uh, and I, I decided on these like four things because I wanted it to be like, even if I don't find anything, there should be like a, a tangible, like outcome at the end.
Um, but.
I have failed with like most of these ones.
Uh, I love the first one is like, get org.
Like what every bug hunter says they're gonna do.
They're like, I'm gonna have this automation.
It's automation is gonna be like finding all these bugs.
Yeah.
And I'm just gonna be like writing my notes and got my whole like API documentation built out.
No, no, no.
It doesn't work.
I mean, I spent so much time like going through my like 200, the Chrome tabs, 200 visual studio code, like unsaved documents that I just create like on the fly.
Yeah.
Astif.txt.
Uh, like just trying.
So I've been trying hard to get more organized, but I'm, yeah, I, I really fail at it.
This is, this is also one of the things I, I really, I, I've been talking to the Kaido team about as well as like, I think one of the niches where Kaido could really shine is this whole concept of organization within your, your, your sort of hacking.
Um, and I think there's a couple of ways that you could go about it.
Obviously we need notes and stuff like that inside of that environment, but, um, uh, auto naming, you know, tabs, trying, trying to keep stuff unified and in one place and, and assisting very cognizantly with organization could be, I think a really big niche for, um, for tooling, uh, in this industry.
Because everyone struggles with that same thing that you just mentioned.
Yeah.
Um, and I mean, as you have seen, like when I've read some of my writeup or like, it's not even writeups, it's a bug reports.
Like I spend so much time.
Like I had this, uh, day, like a Monday, two weeks or one week ago, maybe.
Uh, I spent the whole day writing two reports.
Like my, all the, my six hours went into that.
Oh my goodness, dude.
And so that's, I, I cannot understand these people who are just like, yes, reported that.
And that's me.
So let's talk through that.
Um, but, but before we get to that, I want to go back and look at your goals.
So, um, you know, getting tools, automation, you know, organized that's everyone's goal in the beginning.
Makes sense is that one sort of fell off the horse.
Um, deep diving a couple targets.
What targets did you pick and how is that going?
So that's not going, uh, that well.
Uh, I can, I picked GitLab.
Surprise, surprise.
Yeah.
Uh, so I, I'm still happy with what I've been doing.
So I've had like two main tracks.
Uh, one has been like deep diving some stuff, uh, in the GitLab.
And, but then I also have had this, like where I've been deep diving a topic and applying that more broadly, uh, across like a couple of programs.
So I, I had one week when I tried to learn everything I could about this AI chat attacks.
Uh, and, and then I just went to, because that's everywhere now.
So you just go, uh, everywhere and you try it.
And I try to focus on, uh, like big public programs because I, I don't, I don't know.
The, the private invites things that those are really not for me because I don't, I don't get any good ones.
Like the big public ones are better.
We gotta fix that.
Okay.
I mean, the, the big public ones are like, they pay a lot and, uh, they are usually like very like well oiled.
That's true.
So, and everyone has to be able to do that.
Yeah.
And everyone has this like chat thing.
So I, I, then I just like jumped around on all these programs and like tried it out and like tried to understand.
So those, I did like three of these weeks in the beginning.
Like when I just focused on one type of bug and really tried to like deep dive in that.
Uh, and that was like really, a really amazing experience.
Nice.
And having the time to like spend like five days doing that instead of just like two hours here and here.
You can make so much more progress when you put this time into this.
And, and it's something we talk about as well.
A lot in bug bounty is like this whole concept of like, yeah.
Yeah.
You know, a lot of people want to do this two hours, you know, at the night or on the weekends or something like that when they've got time.
Um, and, and they get frustrated when they don't see success.
And, and I think it takes time.
It takes time to be able to do it in two hours on the weekend.
And it takes time to be able to do it, you know, part time, um, and to get to that point.
And it's possible 100% to do it, you know, just like you mentioned, but there's a lot of buildup that comes up to that because your, your progress is so much slower when you're not able to devote eight hours into deep diving a topic.
Um, so I kind of, I had this idea in my head when starting this, that I would become this, like the hacker, you know, like opening up the burp or Kaido.
And just like going to new fresh target and like looking at the requests and like finding these kind of issues there.
Uh, but as it turns out, like, that's probably not who I am.
So I just ended up like looking at this, like super niche, uh, book.
So the first week I spent on this bug type, like read us, like regex, dos, regex, dos.
All right.
Very nice.
And, uh, yeah, so I had the, so that's one of my first like payouts.
Now they have fixed it in the Git lab.
That's, uh, actually like a high, uh, severity bug, uh, in the latest, uh, release.
Yeah.
So that was really nice.
I actually know somebody else who, who also goes after, uh, read us in, in Git lab.
It seems to be like a pretty common problem in that environment.
Um, unfortunately they have like, just, they have patched it in, uh, like at the language level.
Oh, okay.
So right now, like right after my week of the deep diving, they actually put it out of scope
because they will fix it, uh, like after the summer.
Wow.
So now the, the glory days of, uh, that's Ruby then, or is that, uh, yeah, Ruby Ruby.
Okay.
So, so Ruby's regular expression library.
Yeah.
Their engine has, uh, they are, they fixed, uh, the big issues with it.
And they also put in like a timer that you can set because there are still ways to get
it to, uh, DOS, but, uh, the, you, they also have this like timer option now.
So you can say like anything that runs more than like a minute, uh, just kill the process.
And then it's, uh, sort of impossible to get.
Gotcha.
Okay.
So you, you deep dive that in.
It's possible in some languages, but you know, maybe, maybe not as, as much in, in Ruby.
No, but, uh, it was still fun.
And you did the, you did the chap, chap bugs.
Did you find anything cool there worth sharing?
Or I know we, we discussed it a little bit beforehand and it's a little bit, it's a little bit shallow at this point, but.
Yeah, I mean, so that was kind of what I, what I found out about it is that it's actually pretty hard to find any like, uh, CVSS, uh, like to increase it from like a low medium sort of like you, if the, you have to find programs where they actually integrate these toolings, uh, as you kind of did with the, the Google thing or whatever that was the barred, uh, chat thingy.
Yeah.
Cause I think a lot of this stuff with AI is just like, it's only as powerful as they let it be.
Right.
So like, it doesn't, it doesn't integrate itself in terms of like, make like you say, I want to do this thing.
And it doesn't just like magically know how to do that.
Right.
An engineer has to say, okay, if they want to do this thing, then, you know, do X, Y, Z on the back end, like make this API call or whatever.
And so it has to be integrated to some level, like a technical, right.
Right there.
It doesn't have its own agency.
So you have to find those areas where you get some agency.
And I think it's like valuable to look into because it's probably just going to get worse before it gets better.
Like when everyone just integrates more and more stuff, uh, into it.
Uh, so it's, it's, it was like interesting, but, um, yeah, it wasn't that, uh, from what, where I could tell now, I didn't find that much like super, uh, interesting function healthy with it.
It's fun to play with like trying to trick this chat bot to like tell you stuff.
But I think that's, I think that's a common experience, you know, to be honest, the most, I think the biggest thing that's going to tell you whether there's going to be chat related bugs, um, is, is what, what features that whole chat thing has in the first place.
Cause if you're just chatting, it's like, okay, well I can make you say, you know, some bad word or whatever, but, uh, the impact.
It was like that.
It was like that, that car chat bot that was like, some guy was like chatting with the car dealership and got the chat bot to say that, you know, give him this crazy low like payment deal or whatever on the car.
And he was like, you know, you guys have to uphold this now or something.
Yeah.
That was pretty crazy pressing to be perfectly honest.
I, I was a little surprised to see that actually happen.
Um, but okay.
So you did AI chat bot, you did read us, um, which is a cool, a cool category.
And then you did OAuth as well.
Right.
That one seems a little bit more juicy.
Yeah.
That's sort of, uh, compared to the AI stuff, like, OAuth is like the gift that keeps on giving.
It really is man.
Every time.
A curse that keeps on giving.
Yeah.
Right.
Every time you look into it, you, you find some new like edge case that, um, um, that you can like dig into.
Um, so, uh, and, and then you always have to go back to this, like, uh, France Rose and, uh, dirty dancing thing.
And you find some new edge case in there as well.
And, uh, so.
Very, very formative research there.
Yeah.
Yeah, definitely.
And that was also like moving, jumping around between different, uh, programs.
So I actually found some fun bugs that I cannot really disclose.
Uh, and that's on other programs than GitLab.
So, um, very nice.
Also like.
So you're like, how are you feeling at this point about like income and like, um, the day to day life of full-time bug bounty?
Are you, are you enjoying it?
Are you stressed?
Is the income there?
How's it going?
So I have a problem that I, I target program, uh, programs that are pretty slow.
Like they are, they are, they are like, have a good reputation of paying whenever, like when they have finally fixed it.
But it's, uh, yeah.
So even like GitLab can take a couple of months before you get anything out of, because they pay, they pay some, sometimes at initial triage, but otherwise they pay when they fix it.
And it could take like two, three months for maybe if it's a medium.
Um, so I have this spreadsheet now when I have, I have added like three tables, like what I've gotten paid, what I believe is like a minimum, what I will get and a maximum what I will get.
And then I have this span now from like the, what could be like the possible, like the best possible outcome.
And then I have this, what maybe could end up.
That's, that sounds like a very, a very wise way of doing it.
I think this is one of the things that for me took a while in bug bounty.
Um, because you know, I'll, my normal flow is like, like, you know, clickety clickety, I'm hacking stuff.
Oh, I got it.
You know, I popped it.
And then I like get up and I run into the other room and I tell Mariah, I'm like, I just popped in a hundred K bug.
And she's like, okay, just, just, just chill out here.
Like that's don't count your eggs before they're in the basket or something.
I forget.
So she's got some saying she always says like that.
Um, but it's wise because at the end of the day, like you don't, you don't know how it's going to turn out.
You know, there could be mitigating factors that you're unaware of, um, that sort of thing.
And that can crush you.
Yeah.
I definitely try to not celebrate before they pay because sometimes even like a bug that is from in like triage state, it can move to, uh, like a duplicate or whatever, like whenever they, they find.
It can, it can, well, that's good.
It seems like you've got some good, healthy, healthy, um, you know, sort of heart saving, uh, boundaries in place there.
So you've got this, this sheet set up and maybe most of your bugs haven't gotten paid out yet.
Um, but, uh, it's looking pretty good though.
It's looking good.
Uh, I've, I've been able to pay my first two salaries, which is, uh, great.
Yeah.
Uh, and that, uh, so the, no, it's, it's looking good.
Definitely.
I I'm still, it's still hard for me to, to understand if this is like, uh, if I could do this, if it will like continue trickling bugs.
I still, I'm still at this, uh, place where I feel like whenever I've submitted something, I kind of feel like this is the last bug I will ever find.
Classic.
I become a classic.
It was, it was worse before, but so now I'm kind of feel like I will eventually find something new, but I don't really know when it will happen.
Yeah.
Um, but it also helps.
So targeting, for example, GitLab, I don't have to find that money bugs on those kinds of programs to actually pay my, uh, whatever, like my, what my goal is.
Right.
Yeah.
It's good.
It's good when you can sort of, uh, it's helpful in the beginning when you can couple high paying programs with a lower, you know, uh, budget.
If you're able to control your, your expenditures for a little while, um, while you're building up that confidence and while you're building up that, that sum of money in your, in your company account that will eventually, you know, pay out your salary.
Um, so I think that's, I think that's a really wise way of approaching it and how I recommend most people start bug bounty, um, full-time as well is, is that sort of, um, you know, uh, smaller amounts, you know, decrease the cost of living and get that freedom back where you can work on whatever you want every day and then kind of move from there.
Um, are, are you, I wanted to ask this as well.
Are you working at home?
Do you work at your home environment?
Do you work from like an office or a cafe or anything like that?
Or I've been, so this is maybe something that will like get to me.
Uh, if I spend, like, if I do this more that I've been sitting at home a lot, mostly because I don't like, I, it takes too much time to get away somewhere.
And I have my equipment here and I have my screen and everything.
Uh, so I've been sitting mostly at home, but I've also went some days to a cafe and that really helps to like clear your mind.
To reset, right?
Yeah.
I do, I do a similar thing.
It's like, I got my home base.
It's normally fine, but sometimes I gotta like shake it and get out and like freshen things up and then you can come back to it.
And I think some people, they have to work at cafes or they have to work in these co-working environments.
I just like, if I had to do that every day, that would be a really big inhibitor for me.
I think.
No, but, but, so that is, I don't, but I have not found any problem with getting to work.
It's more, I have more issues with like structuring my time.
So I, I kind of have this to-do list for a day and I know that I have to do these, like four things.
I have to answer some person on a report or whatever.
And then I, I tell myself like in the morning, like, but I, if I just look a little bit on this, like, don't purify bypass thing.
And then like three hours later, I'm just like, okay, I have to do some work now.
I just.
Yeah, man.
So that happens a lot.
Like I'm, I'm very easily as you have maybe seen sometimes, uh, nerd snipable as well.
So I spend a lot of time doing stuff that is not really relevant.
That's great.
My favorite kind of hacker to collab with a nerd snipable hacker.
No, it's good though, man, because you can deep dive the stuff that you're really interested in and, and you kind of get focused on that.
Um, so that is definitely a superpower in some capacity and a hindrance in others.
Um, but I'm excited to hear you say, you know, that you, you've been, uh, you know, succeeding with it so far and it's been, it's been a fun experiment.
And hopefully the rest of those, those bugs will get paid out soon and you'll be feeling better about the results.
Uh, you know, the biggest problem I've had, it has been like this separation of work and, uh, free time.
Like when I go to my day job, it's very like, even if I work from home, it's very obvious that I do like this external work for someone else.
And then at a certain time I just like quit and I, I do whatever.
Like now it's been more like maybe sort of like my wife asks me like, are you working now or like in the evening?
Like, are you working now or are you not?
And then I say like, no, no, not real.
I'm just like having some fun.
Yeah.
And personally, I think I prefer that sort of stance on because unless you're doing very like singular work where like you can spend like dedicated chunks of time working on one thing,
life doesn't really work like that a lot of the time.
And so it's really, really difficult to just say like, Oh, for this eight hours of the day, I'm just gonna not do anything except for this one thing.
Like, you know, stuff happens, stuff comes up and being able to be flexible in that sense is really nice where you can be like, Oh, I need to go do this thing in the middle of the day.
And then you come back and you sort of shift those hours around where you wouldn't maybe be working after 5 PM normally, but now you do because instead of, you know, working at noon,
you were doing something else.
And so now you need to work later.
And so, you know, like that, I think that flexibility is just nice to have the option, even if most of the time you do work normal hours, being able to shift stuff around and have that flexibility is super nice.
It certainly is.
And, and I've talked about this little sign on the, on the podcast before, but you might have to move it over a little bit for it to show up.
Can you see it?
Cause I'm like, put it, I'm just going to put it right in front of my face, but put it around the middle.
Yeah.
It says, it says, um, a guilt in Japanese and the backside, it says take UB and these mean, you know, open for business and closed for business.
And it's just, I've thought about this so many times.
It's so helpful, man, to have these little, these little things like this, that, that you can, um, you know, put in your life, especially when you're an entrepreneur, when you're, you're self-employed to sort of differentiate in your brain.
This is work and this is play, you know?
Um, especially when it overlaps so much for us that are hobbyists, you know, first in bug bounty and then have transitioned into a full-time job because of the freedom benefits and the, and the, um, I guess just quality of life increase.
So, uh, there's lots of little hacks like that, that I'm sure you'll, you'll develop.
And it's also helps with, with the wife too, because, you know, if you're spending so much time, um, you know, working and, and they're trying to like respect your work time and that sort of thing.
But also like, if you're just, you know, flittedy hacking or just like, you know, really doing something from a hobby perspective, then you could say, Hey, you want to like go for a walk in the garden or something like that versus distracting you from work.
So I think it's helpful to have those sorts of things in place.
And I actually had like, that's one of my, one experience I had that was like, that surprised me.
That was, was supposed to be, uh, really like, uh, uh, a good thing, but then it turned into sort of a bad thing was that I, I went for a, like a break, like a vacation over Easter to, um, to Stockholm, to my, my parents with the whole family.
And because I don't have like work hours now, we were just like, yeah, yes, we just drive on Thursday.
And then we came back a week later and then it was weekend again.
And all of a sudden I had like 10 days that I hadn't really done anything.
And then I started to get really stressed that it was like this unplanned leave, uh, from my own work.
Yep.
Because I could just do it, but I didn't really think through it, uh, in the beginning to say, like, I need to still work like one or two days this week to get like my mental, you know, in a good state with this like thing that I do.
And then you feel like you're like out of, out of the loop or out of your groove and stuff like that.
Definitely.
It, it, so after that, I actually had also my, my worst week during this that I didn't find anything before like Friday afternoon.
I find it like this small, like, uh, really low.
Yeah.
I mean, this is my biggest thing is that generally, like, I think for a lot of people, regardless of life situation, it's really important to have some sort of scheduled structured routine that you follow.
Like regardless of if you're employed or whatever, like at least wake up at the same time and like, dude, like make a coffee, like you're like have some order of events, even if, even if it's not like at the same time and stuff, but just some sort of structured routine that you can follow.
That helps give you like a grounding that every day, like you either start at the same or you do something that like helps you like, no, like, okay, like now I can start or I can like do the things that I need to do today.
Instead of sort of just waking up and be like, what should I do today?
Cause that's a lot I found personally, especially like very, very difficult for me, for myself to stay on track.
If I don't set myself like things that I want to be doing and things that I aim to actually do.
And just instead of, if I approach it just sort of like, as it rolls, I'll find that I do a lot less and I'm a lot less intentional with the stuff that I'm doing.
Yeah.
And, and I think from my, from my side as well, having experiences, uh, many times, very similar to what you just described of like.
Oh wow.
I accidentally just took two weeks off or like, you know, 10 days off or whatever.
And I'm coming back to this and it's like, okay.
Um, now I'm stressed.
I think it, it, it helps, you know, in those sort of contexts to be like, yeah, but I just took 10 days off, you know, like, and I just like, man, how grateful am I that I just have that flexibility and that, and that, um, that ability to do that and reflect on that.
And that, that, that's been really helpful for me and realize that that is my right as a, as a self-employed person, because I'm making trade-offs.
I don't have a guaranteed income coming in.
And, and that obviously, um, has stress associated with it and that stress has to have a trade-off and that trade-off.
And that trade-off I told myself, you know, when I did full-time bike bounty was going to be the flexibility.
And if I can't enjoy that flexibility, then I'm, I'm, it's not a good deal.
So you, you gotta like, I don't know, for me, I was kind of like, you know, like really twisting my own arms to like make me enjoy it.
You kind of have to learn to be conscious about it, I guess as well, like actually understanding, like now I'm going to do this and it's going to take.
Yeah.
From.
I think a good way to think about is like, kind of like the unlimited PTO thing that, that a lot of tech companies give.
Right.
So like as a self-employed person, you basically have unlimited paid time off.
Well, time off.
Let's not say paid time off.
Hold up.
Right.
So, so the real key is how do you turn this into unlimited paid time off?
Because, you know, at the end of the day, you're, you're the one who, who payrolls.
Yeah.
And so, you know, finding that balance between like the time off and using that time off and not working yourself to the bone, but also making sure that you are working and finding, you know, the time to, to balance work and family and not just like, woo, like no obligations.
Let's go.
You know, like, yeah, I think it's really important.
Um, the, the, the other day I took.
It was like a Tuesday or something.
And I went and played pickleball with my friends, uh, you know, at 1 PM on a Tuesday, uh, my only other friends that can go play a pickleball at 1 PM on a Tuesday.
And I was like, wow, I'm so grateful for this because there's no one at the pickleball courts.
The weather is beautiful.
You know, it's just like, and it's, uh, it's what a blessing to be able to do that.
And I think sort of meditating in those moments and being like, this is why I do, you know, full-time book bounty, um, really helps with that.
And it sounds like you're on the path to that as well, which is really good.
Well, I think I have to do this for a longer period to start to not feel stressed because I only have these, like the limited, uh, three months.
So I kind of want to make it worth it.
But I also, I listened again, I've listened a couple of times to the, the pod with the Alex Chapman.
Yeah.
And he mentioned something that I try to like stay true to, which is like, he's not doing this to get rich.
Like the thing with that, you can actually get like a lot of money, but you also have to like realize why you are doing it.
So, and that's true for me as well.
Like the point of it is to be able to do what I find interesting and fun.
And I have to remind myself of that.
Like, so I thought that I would be this guy, like opening burp and like finding those kinds of bugs.
And that's like finding like 200 IDORS, sending them in and like getting rich, but that's not even what I'm like interested in.
Like, so why would I do that?
Right.
If I find the bugs that pay my bills, then I can try to spend time on like this really niche things.
And while doing that, so like one of the points I had, what is like doing three write ups or like blog posts.
And I, that kind of, I stressed out about it.
And then I started writing one that I was planning to release like before this podcast.
And when I was doing the write up, I found the bypass to the bug that I was doing the write up for.
So that was great.
Like I had to scrap the blog post for now.
But like, just, I really like this word, the serendipity, which is like this idea of like, if you just do stuff, like the luck comes to you.
Like if you, if you just keep on doing things, it will just happen.
Yeah.
And I feel like that happens to me a lot.
Like a lot of the bugs I found find are coming just like they just appear appearing where I happen to dig at the moment.
Serendipitous.
Like there are things like everywhere.
Yeah.
No, that's, that's a great perspective, man.
It seems like, it seems like you got the mental for bug bounty, man.
And I know, I know it's different to talk about it on a podcast, um, versus like actually implementing it in your own life and whether you can control those, um, you know, stressful, stressful times or whatever.
But I think, like you said, as time passes, as you get more acclimated to that life and you become more confident in the fact like, okay, I can take two weeks off and feel out of my element and then get back in my element.
Um, you know, diving back in and stuff like that.
Like you did that one time, right.
Um, where you found the bug on Friday.
Um, I think that for me, it, it hasn't gone away quite as much, but it's nice to also, you know, communicate with your spouse as well and say like, Hey, like, no, you probably just all of a sudden haven't.
Lost your, your, you know, ability to do this thing that you've been doing nonstop for the past, like five or six years, you know?
Um, and have, have them remind you of that.
Um, right.
Does such a great job of that.
And it, it, it really, um, really helps my mental in those times where I'm like, yeah, you know what?
Actually I found the last bug I'm ever going to find ever again.
And I'm just like done as a hacker now.
Um, so yeah, it's, it's a holistic thing, man.
Full-time bug bounty, you know, and it really does help to have a great teammate as well.
I will say though, like, uh, you know, that that's only like 50% of the battle.
Right.
So like, uh, the other parts inside your own head.
So you, you have to make sure that like, uh, you know, yeah, you have somebody backing you up, but then when you go and sit down, the person who you're fighting with the most is yourself.
And so being able to like deal with that and cope with that, um, when you're like, you know, hands on keyboard is also really important.
Yeah.
It is.
Well, uh, Johan, thanks so much for sharing all this stuff, man.
It was an awesome episode filled with technical information, full-time bug bounty information, just a, a quality, uh, bug bounty episode.
So thanks for all that, man.
Um, anything you want to shout before we, uh, close this podcast out.
Hmm.
I always ask people that at the end and they're not prepared.
So, uh, no, no, not really.
Um, I mean, people can, uh, I try to keep my DMS and stuff open everywhere.
So feel free to reach out.
Like, uh, that's one dangerous.
Yeah.
It's definitely, but, but it's also like with the caveat that I'm, I'm really bad at answering because I, I, I put that on my to-do list and it gets pushed down, uh, all the time.
But I tried at least if people reach out with like actual questions or like concrete, like how can I do this or whatever.
Um, I, I try to, uh, answer them eventually.
Like it can take a long time, but then I do it.
And it can lead, it can lead to good collabs for you too.
Like, like you mentioned, and I I've said this before on the pod, but like, since we launched this pod, I've definitely made five figures worth of bounties from people reaching out to me saying, Hey, here's this bug.
I can't fully exploit it.
And then I fully exploit it and we, you know, get some percentage of it.
So, um, why is, why is shout out there?
Johan, I see you trying to steal some of my collabs.
Oh, I see how it is.
It doesn't, it, it have happened to me as well, but I have one issue with it, which is, uh, in Sweden here, we have really like strict tax laws.
Oh, really?
So it's really hard for me to like collab if it's not like an official collab so that we can split it like on the platform.
I don't even know how I would like, uh, tell the tax authorities about someone just sending me like a bunch of money.
And I'm saying it's like, yeah, that was a collab.
Like it, it will not work.
So it has to be a very like official, unfortunately, uh, because some programs don't allow you to collaborate and, um,
Should make collaboration on by default.
Yeah.
Program platform.
100.
So, uh, this is still a thing.
Who knows, man, who knows?
Um, but yeah, definitely hit Johan up if you've got any crazy CSP bypasses or client side bugs you need exploited.
And yeah, I think we'll wrap it there because there's a con, uh, you know, construction noises in my house that we're going to have to cut out.
So someone's about to fall through Justin's ceiling.
All right.
Good pod guys.
Peace.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for listening.
And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctpb.show slash discord.
Join the discord.
There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there.
And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us.
We'll see you there.